What would happen if you fell into a black
hole?
If you'd asked Albert Einstein, he would have told you
that according
to his general theory of relativity, you'd be sucked into the black hole singularity,
the point where space-time curves steeply inward and all the laws of physics seem to break down.
After that, nothing can escape.
In the 1970s, Stephen Hawking took a semi-classical approach to
black holes,
bringing together quantum theory and Einstein's relativity.
He proved that black holes
emit a small amount of heat that eventually causes the black hole to evaporate.
Still, according
to Hawking, if you fell into a black hole, you and your particles would be
lost to the universe forever.
This is Don Page.
He was a postdoc with
Stephen Hawking, where they became friends
despite the fact that they ultimately landed
on either side of one of the most controversial debates in modern physics.
Page: I looked at
Hawking's argument and became not convinced by it.
Hawking's work implied that black holes violated
a central principle of quantum mechanics,
called unitarity, which says that the
present always preserves information about the past.
So how could it be possible that
black holes destroy information?
This became known as the black hole information paradox,
and for decades. it made physicists queasy.
According to Page, if you were to fall into
a black hole,
you wouldn't be gone for good.
Particle by particle, the information needed
to reconstitute your body would re-emerge.
Page: Well, it would be highly scrambled by
the black hole.
It'd be much worse than even, you know, if you just
cremated the body and
it turned into smoke and ashes.
But you know, another analogy is if you burn up a book,
and you have all the ashes the information is still somewhere there,
is somewhere
in the universe, we believe.
The key to understanding why the information is preserved
lies in a process called quantum entanglement.
When black holes emit radiation, that radiation
maintains a quantum mechanical link
to its place of origin.
If you tried to measure the radiation
or the black hole, separately
the information would look random.
But when you look at them
together, they exhibit a pattern.
Page: You know, if somebody took a coin and and cut it in half
and then you sort of shook it up and put it in two envelopes and send it off to two people,
then
of course there would be what we call correlations in it. If one person gets a head, they know the
other person would have tails.
And this quantum entanglement is like that, except it's an even
more subtle.
This is the Page curve, which he created to track changes in the entanglement
between a black hole and its radiation as it ages.
The degree to which the information is
entangled is called its entanglement entropy.
At the start of a black hole's life,
its entanglement entropy is zero,
since it hasn't emitted any radiation.
And at
the end, its entanglement entropy is zero again,
since the black hole has evaporated.
But
in between, as radiation trickles out, the entanglement entropy grows.
Page showed that, in
theory, information can escape from a black hole.
In a series of groundbreaking papers,
physicists
have shown that the entanglement entropy of black holes really does follow the Page curve.
Page:
These calculations give more evidence that indeed
the information does come out, but the
details of how that actually happens,
you know, still remain to be, remain to be
understood.
And it of course it raises the picture that maybe space time itself is not fundamental.
Maybe there's something
deeper than space time, and maybe the basic quantum
description will
involve something that's not space and time.
So I think there'll be parts of the puzzle I
think that'll persist for many more decades.
Another puzzle that's baffled the scientific
community for decades is super conductivity.
When various solids are cooled to extremely low
temperatures,
they can conduct electricity without losing energy.
This happens because the freezing
temperature allows electrons to move slowly enough to overcome their natural repulsion with
each other,
and they begin to form pairs.
Like any good couple should,
they balance each other out,
and begin to move in the same direction.
When
this happens, electrical resistance disappears.
This is what makes superconductivity
the holy grail of energy efficiency,
if only scientists could overcome
the limitations of temperature.
This is Ranga Dias.
This year, he and a team at
the University of Rochester created a metallic compound that, for the first time,
exhibited
superconductivity at room temperature.
Dias: So you have a very small two diamond tips
that's sitting opposite to each other,
and then you put your sample that you need
to study in between those diamond tips,
so you can apply force mechanically.
Dias's team
applied pressures almost as extreme as those found at the earth's core.
They did this by crushing the
compound inside a microscopic niche they carved out of a diamond anvil.
Then, they triggered
chemical reactions with a laser beam.
Dias: So that way, we were able to really find the
room temperature superconductor.
You know, it's under pressure, right? What we have found
is under pressure, so somebody can argue that, 'Okay,
so you went from one extreme to
another extreme, so who cares?
You know, what's a big deal, in that sense, right?
But I think, there was a time that we were, even the scientists were thinking that
a room
temperature superconductor is not possible.
To be honest,
the very first time when we
saw this one, I didn't really believe it,
and it was like okay this is too good to be
true, and why we are seeing this nice resistance?
Everybody around the world contacted me via email
or phone calls, and they were very excited and this is a landmark discovery.
But there are
a lot of, you know, a lot of work to be done,
because even though we know the
initial composition, you know,
what are the material that we put together to
pressurize it, but we don't know actually what itis,
really what the sample is superconducting.
So that, those studies need to be done.
So for now, levitating trains, lossless power
transmission, and perfect energy storage are still utopian dreams.
But Dias believes they're not
far off.
Dias: I would say I'm very optimistic. Probably in the next five years, or ten years,
we may be able to get to a real application.
In 2006, an astronomer detected a brief
and extremely powerful radio signal coming
from a distant galaxy.
Over the next
few years, dozens more were observed.
Astronomers traded wild theories
trying to explain them.
This year, a fast radio burst was observed again,
but this
time it came within our own galaxy.
In just a millisecond, the source emitted 100 million times
more power than the sun.
Brian Metzger and his colleagues at Columbia University analyzed
the data, and found the source:
a magnetar.
Metzger: So a magnetar is a neutron star.
So neutron stars form when massive stars die
at the end of their lives. The core of the
star collapses in and forms a neutron star,
a very compact object about the mass of our sun,
but the size of New York City.
And then the outer layers of the star explode as a supernova, so a
neutron star is what's left over.
And a magnetar
is an extreme version of a neutron star with
a very strong magnetic field.
So there was a magnetar in our own galaxy that produced a flare
of x-rays,
and arriving on Earth at essentially the same time as the x-rays was
a burst of radio
emission, which if we put it into a different, distant galaxy would have looked a lot like a fast
radio burst.
But we were, you know, identifying that it came from a magnetar within our own
galaxy.
So that's pretty good circumstantial evidence,
you know, that magnetars can produce
fast radio bursts.
That's why fast radio bursts are great, because we can see them almost to
the edge of the universe, and so
in addition to actually understanding what's producing them
one of the exciting things is we can use them as as probes
of the state of matter between us and
the and the radio source.
And so I think that's, you know, very exciting as we discover more and
more fast radio bursts.
And if it turns out that they come from magnetars, then we're also probing
where all the magnetars are in the whole universe, which is something we didn't think,
you
know, would have ever been possible.